[Music]
from the nation's capital the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research presents public policy forums a
series of programs featuring the
nation's top authorities presenting
their differing views on the vital
issues which confront us today's topic
the future of chinese-american relations
following more than a generation in
which the United States gave its total
support to the 17 million Chinese on the
island of Formosa in December of 1978
this country abruptly switched sides we
did a 180 degree turn
recognized the communist government in
Peking and withdrew recognition of the
Taiwan government why George Bush who
spent three years as a u.s.
representative in Peking leading up to
formal recognition calls it a mindless
abandonment saying the deal made with
the mainline government was almost
totally one-sided why did this country
Bush asks give up such a trusted
longtime ally without demanding more in
return such as a Peking guarantee not to
attack Taiwan what does the Peking for
Taiwan switch tell the rest of the world
about us promises what will be the
political and economic benefits or
drawbacks that will flow from us
recognition of Peking is it true as
ambassador Bush puts it that China needs
the United States far more than the US
needs China that the recognition of
Peking plays mostly into the hands of
the Russians what will be the future of
American relations with Taiwan welcome
to another public policy forum presented
by AEI the American Enterprise Institute
a nonprofit nonpartisan research and
education organization today's
roundtable discussion will consider the
future of chinese-american relations
appearing on the panel our senator Barry
Goldwater Republican of Arizona senator
Goldwater is serving his fourth term in
the US Senate he's the ranking
Republican member of the Senate Select
Intelligence Committee and is a member
of both the Armed Services Committee and
the Committee on Commerce science and
transportation senator Goldwater was the
Republican candidate for president in
1964 senator Alan Cranston Democrat of
California
Senator Cranston who is assistant Senate
Majority Leader is serving his second
term in the US Senate he was a leader in
congressional efforts to end the Vietnam
War and has long been an advocate of
effective arms control and reduction
senator Cranston is chairman of the
Senate Veterans Affairs Committee he is
a member of the Human Resources
Committee and the Committee on Banking
Housing and Urban Affairs Senator Bob
Dole republican of kansas senator dole
is in his second term as a u.s. senator
having served four terms previously as a
US congressman he is the ranking
Republican member of the Senate Finance
Committee and a member of both the
Judiciary Committee and the Committee on
agriculture and forestry senator Dole
was the Republican nominee for vice
president in 1976 representative
Jonathan Bingham Democrat liberal of New
York congressman Bingham has served in
Congress since 1965 he is chairman of
the Subcommittee on economic policy and
trade of the House Foreign Affairs
Committee he is a member of the House
Commission that monitors the Helsinki
Accords congressman Bingham has served
as a US Representative to several United
Nations assemblies and on UN committees
John Charles daily will moderate the
discussion mr. Daley has served as News
correspondent and analyst for CBS News
and for ABC News and as a vice president
of the ABC network he is a former
director of The Voice of America now
here is mr. Daley this public policy
forum part of a series presented by the
American Enterprise Institute is
concerned with a dragon reborn with the
nation to which it is said the 20th 21st
century will belong our subject the
future of chinese-american relations
after a century of self-destruction and
humiliation by the nations of the modern
industrial world China in 1949 in the
words of motsi dong stood up under the
Communist banner and the sayings of
Mao's little red book one quarter of the
world's population was reorganized into
the largest single society in this world
concentrated on self-sufficiency and
building progress has been noteworthy
over the past 30 years most notable may
be the fact that the process has
survived the violent disruptions of the
Great Leap Forward in the late 50s and
the Cultural Revolution of the late 60s
today China seems better prepared than
at any time in the past century to
handle its own enormous problems and to
participate in the world economic
society China's role in the
International order has grown by leaps
and bounds by deeds and by daring role
in Korea and Vietnam in the 50s and 60s
atomic capability in 1964 direct
confrontation with the Soviet Union in
the 60s full representation in the
United Nations in the 70s and a
punishing limited invasion of Vietnam in
1979 looming overall in the relations
between the United States and China vast
differences in culture and the inability
of the Western community to comprehend
the intricacies and the subtleties of
Chinese policy thinking and policymaking
so senator Goldwater have we now in the
search for stability in Asia move from
confrontation to date on as we did in
Europe well I have to start off by
saying that we have had no
confrontations in that part of the world
since Vietnam now getting it
specifically to China I don't know how
we can avoid doing everything in our
power to make our recognition go
although I would not approve of it if it
had been put to a vote it's a part of
the world that is of more importance to
the United States I think than any other
part of the world the Far Pacific in
fact the parameter of the Pacific has
been the focal point of our foreign
policy now for over a hundred years and
I think a lot depends on what China does
about this in respect to our relations
and what we do in respect to China in
our relations it's going to take time I
think we have to recognize that I think
the tendency will be to say at the end
of six months well it isn't working we
have to remember that the Chinese have
been in government for over 3,000 years
and we haven't been in it but a few
years over 200 and it always amuses me
when we send our diplomats over to China
or those Asian countries with the
200-year background talking to those
experts in fact I think when Minh Tong
k'ittain came to this country the best
cartoon I saw was him walking down the
street shaking the president's hand and
the president says ma he has a firm grip
and the president was about three feet
off the ground I think the the big
question here that has to be developed
is what does all of this mean to Russia
up until the time we recognized at Red
China
I felt that any confrontation between
Russia and Red China would bring on
World War three now I have some change
thoughts on that and where we might fit
in the picture but I think it's way too
early to be able to be specific I'll
just close by saying in view of the way
we treated Taiwan
how will the smaller countries of that
area of the world feel about trusting us
and I think that's an important question
that we have to see answered well I
think we will come to discuss that
question senator Cranston what do you
see as the political and economic
benefits of our new relationship with
vaping well in terms of world politics
it enables us to leave a ridiculous
position we held the position that all
of China was ruled from Taiwan which it
was was not we now recognize that it is
from Peking and so far as a mainland is
concerned it enables the most powerful
nation on the face of the earth and
that's us the United States to deal
directly with the most populous nation
on the face of the earth China and it
seems to me that it was rather difficult
to come to grips with some worldwide
problems that affect us all when we were
barely on speaking terms we do have the
task of making plain that we are not
selling Taiwan down the river
I think action taken in the Senate as we
approved some legislation establishing
our relations with Taiwan in a new way
have shown our concern about that and in
the course of time we will show that we
can be a trusted friend as I think we
are going to prove we are to Taiwan in
terms of economics it gives us a great
opportunity and gives China a great
opportunity as far as our opportunity is
concerned we can sell a lot of American
products cotton coca-cola and a lot of
other things to the people of China we
can receive some material we need from
them it will be particularly good for
port states like California my
California and I'm pleased with that and
will also send a lot of California
cotton to China right senator doe what
do you see as the effect on you as
Soviet relations of our approach more
with the People's Republic of China well
I think very honestly it's a little
early to tell I think the Soviets made
the customary or had the customary
reaction when they learned when the as
the rest of us learned in December about
normalization I don't believe they were
notified before those of us in the
Congress and may have been I heard it on
the radio but in any event I don't
really it's going to take some time
we're going to come to the crunch one of
these days and we get in the most
favored nation treatment of the Soviets
and the Chinese and and how the
so-called jackson-vanik amendment will
come into play so I would guess that in
the next six months or six years
somewhere in that time it'll have an
impact but I don't believe that
I think it's nice to get along with the
Peking that's nice in and of itself but
I don't believe it's going to help
contain a Soviet expansion I don't think
it's going to help extend the boundaries
of freedom I don't think it's going to
be a substitute for a poor assault
agreement and so I hope we just keep our
guard up if I may that Most Favoured
Nation doesn't really describe very
accurately what we're talking about it
doesn't mean that we think Russia should
be the most favored nation on earth or
China if we grant their most favored
nation treatment it means that we cannot
place a duty on anything they sold it
was higher than the duty we place upon
the same product from some other nation
meaning really equality and trade it's a
good deal for the Chinese and be about a
50% reduction we'll come back to these
these specific issues representative
Bingham what effect in your view will
the new relationship with the People's
Republic have on japanese-american
relations I would think all of the good
I think
we've followed a course very close to
the Japanese for a number of years
really since World War two when I was at
the UN we tended to agree with the
Japanese on a bit on the issues more
than with almost any other country and I
think in this case we are following what
they did they set up a relationship with
Peking before we did they can they are
continuing also an informal relationship
with Taiwan and so I think where we're
acting in parallel with them and I can't
see that it will create the slightest
strain it's interesting to recall that
the Japanese and the Chinese have over
the centuries had many conflicts so for
them to make friends with the Chinese
people as perhaps more extraordinary
than for us once again to make friends
with the Chinese people traditionally
Americans and Chinese have had a very
close relationship and I certainly
welcome this development which permits
us once again to make friends with
the great many hundreds of millions of
Chinese well let us come back to the
great issue which senator Goldwater
raised they may ask a question and
perhaps you'd like to start with it
since you raised it senator Goldwater
our even-handed relationships between
the United States and the People's
Republic of China and the United States
and the Soviet Union in reality the best
hope for mankind that there will not be
a nuclear Armageddon and that we can
secure peace on a general basis
throughout the world right now I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that it is the
best answer on the other hand I believe
I will think more of this arrangement
than having just the Soviet as a
potential enemy there's always that old
saying of lets you and him fight that we
are in a rather unusual situation of
having always defended the Soviets and
they have always defended us in times of
trouble and the question arises what
will we do
and I think this is going to be the
great unfolding drama that we're going
to see not so much the the drama and the
work of getting an economy started in
China but the drama of what might happen
between these two countries and at the
same time between the geographic armies
in China how they haven't changed since
the communist regime came in they're
loyal to their warlords they probably
would fight for the central government
but that's there's some question on that
so I would much rather reserve judgment
until we see what happens it's a case I
think of both countries having a
historic purpose of war namely the need
for more land but it seems to me Barry
that that you know this flirtation we're
having with Peking that cannot be a
substitute for us resolve I mean there's
still a weak and impoverished nation
they're closed society they're
totalitarian
they don't share our fundamental beliefs
may be that we gain something because of
normalization I think what disturbed
many of us was not the normalization
with the PRC but the D normalization
with our good friend and ally Taiwan it
disturbed you to the point where you
went to court that's right and I share
your concern but I would hope that we
don't suddenly believe as Americans and
now we have China on the one hand
People's Republic of China and the
Soviets on the other and somehow we can
relax our efforts we've relaxed our
efforts too much now we've cancelled the
b-1 bomber we've slowed down the MX
missile we may or may not have a salt
agreement and so my point would be that
we hope it's a plus but I haven't seen
any evidence of that
senator Christmas on the issue of
denormalizing with Taiwan while
normalizing with the People's Republic
of China we really couldn't have formal
diplomatic relations with both both say
there's only one China
neither would accept a split where each
is recognized as a part of China the
sensible thing to do I believe was what
was done to recognize that China is
governed from Peking and to set up a
special relationship and we do have a
special relationship with Taiwan we had
it before we have it now we are going to
continue to have trade with them
cultural exchanges we continue to have
the perfect right if it ever comes to
any conflict between mainland China and
Peking and I do not think it will to
provide arms and to take any other step
that we deem to be after what
international actors say although we
have a moratorium for one year yes we
have a moratorium for one year but they
are pretty well armed right now and
plainly with China with hostile Vietnam
and part of the border with hostile
Soviet Union over so much of their
border is not about to launch any
aggression against Taiwan it would be an
act of insanity for them to do so beyond
their military capacity to carry out a
very tough amphibious operation
requiring air cover just beyond their
ability against Taiwan which is we all
know is a fortress island
in good part because of the aid we've
given them and their own strength and
determination and skill Jake your
question to have to do with whether we
should favor one over the other
that is whether we should favor China at
the expense of the Soviet Union and I
would not be in favor of that I think
that that summer some people call that
plane with China card I don't think that
would be wise and on the issue of
whether we should give them the
so-called most favored nation treatment
I think it'd be a mistake to do that if
we're not gonna do it too for the Soviet
Union on the other hand it does seem to
me that if you look back to 1954 when
the mutual defense treaty with Taiwan
was entered into and which of course
contained a provision to the effect that
it could be terminated by either party
with one year's notice but when you look
back to that time and compared to now
the change is is remarkable at that time
we were talking about the sino-soviet
bloc and they were considered a block
that was the threat that we saw and that
which brought about the formation of a
number of these mutual defense treaties
today it's not a block its confrontation
between the two each one is very
outspoken about its hatred of the other
so while I would agree with the Senators
that we can't relax our defense
certainly it's enormous advantage to us
in relation to the Communist world that
the two largest communist powers
distrust and hate each other rather than
have them as allies as they were 25
years ago I'd like to I'd like to go
back because I think we're missing part
of this the D recognition of of Taiwan
now we passed by I think four votes
against the resolution back in September
instructing the prayer telling the
president that it was the will of the
Congress that nothing be done in Taiwan
without consultation with the Congress
and he didn't talk to anyone that I know
of in the Congress now outside of the
fact that I feel that the president
acted illegally in this
this is what caused me to take him to
court let me offer a little scenario
that may answer in part some of the
concern here right now the Soviet Navy
is pretty much bottled up in Vladivostok
now we saw them off the shores of Danang
just recently we have reason to believe
that they're making minut passes at Cam
Ranh Bay now let's say that Taiwan says
to the Soviet we would like to be
friends with you you can use our harbors
you can use all that great airbase at
the United States built for us and then
ran off and forgot if that happens and
the Soviets
accept an offer like that to protect
Taiwan from any advances of the mainland
and I might say I agree I think there
probably 20 years away from being able
to even make a pass at KU Moy leave
alone Taiwan but if that happens the
next step is Singapore and then the
Straits of Malacca and with the serious
condition we're in and the Indian Ocean
now I see the complete absence of the
United States in the Far Pacific within
the foreseeable future I think this is
something that the president overlooked
didn't discuss with people who had this
section in mind that's that's my whole
concern about this whole thing yes they
had I think Barry is right that the vote
was 94 to zero and it was an outgrowth
of an amendment that Senator Goldwater
had introduced the year before but it
was compromised to the point that we
would be consulted and I don't think we
should maybe dwell on that it's already
been accomplished but did that in itself
was an indication of mismanagement at
some level Congress was not consulted
even our good friend and Ally Taiwan was
given very little notice maybe five or
six hours the Congress is never happy
with the degree of consultation that the
executive branch gives it but the fact
is that here there had been a lot of
consultation going back many months over
80 meetings and I Wow I can understand
that at the last minute there wasn't as
much notice as members would have liked
to have I think that it's only fair to
record that there had been these a great
deal of speak to that issue to the word
consultation is a very broad word I feel
there was consultation that fits that
definition it certainly could not mean
advice and consent with formal action by
the Senate because it's the president's
authority and power under the
Constitution to decide who to recognize
in the conduct of foreign policy I was
in touch throughout a good part of the
year in regard to concepts and steps
toward normalization of relations others
were consulted others in the Senate were
consulted it was not a matter of telling
us exactly when it was going to happen
but I don't think it was any secret that
we were moving in that direction as a
matter of fact it all began out in the
open when to give him credit Richard
Nixon went to China with Henry Kissinger
and it became American policy and it was
not disputed to move toward
normalization the president does not
have the constitutional authority to
terminate a treaty he has the
constitutional authority to recommend to
the Senate that we form a treaty and we
do that with two-thirds consent and
that's the only way that we can see in
the Constitution that a treaty can be
terminated but I remember the night that
Nixon first went to China I was flying a
jet out to the west coast and they
caught me someplace over Oklahoma and
asked me to call Fort Worth control
because I had a patch in from Andrew so
I called and they put Kissinger on and
he said by the time you land
President Nixon will have announced that
he's going to China will you please keep
your mouth shut and I said yes I'll keep
my mouth shut and in subsequent
discussions he told me and discussions
with other members of the State
Department told me that there was no
idea of terminating a treaty with Taiwan
I have that in writing and this is what
shocked me
was to have the president come out
without any he knew of my great interest
in this in fact he called me one day I
he said I hear you're going to impeach
me if I do anything I said well I might
might try so he knew I was interested
but he didn't even give me the decency
of a call and this is that while it has
nothing to do with a recognition of Red
China that's done and we're not going to
fight that I do think we have to put
this present straight as to whose power
it is to abrogate a treaty Jimmy Carter
is not the first president to terminate
a treaty by his own action first one
first one to ever do it with a mutual
defense treaty are precedents for
terminating treaties and that is a
treaty there was a clause saying it can
be terminated by either party in one
year's notice and one year's notice has
been served in accordance with the
provision we can't find out who the part
what the party means and I hold that it
means the President and the Congress
we've terminated 51 treaties by
legislative action and this is the first
time in the history of our country by
presidential action illegally taken in
my opinion we've terminated a treaty but
I would like very much to do is if we
could all agree there is a legal
question here I have one more point not
on the on the new better shot I've got
another point not on the issue of
whether some of the Goldwater is right
or whether the lawyers are right to say
the president didn't have that the power
to terminate this treaty in accordance
with its terms but I would like to make
the point that seems to me the passage
of the Congress now of the Taiwan
Relations Act their house just recently
passed the conference report the Senate
the same by that action the Congress has
in effect ratified the president's
action of terminating the treaty because
the whole basis for that legislation is
that the treaty in effect has been
terminated by the president's action and
I just like to touch on another point
that very made about the concerns of
aggression by the People's Republic
against Hong Kong Singapore Macau Taiwan
or whatever it would destroy everything
that
the People's Republic hopes to gain in
terms of trade with us stability in
terms of their relationship with Russia
having relationship with us the
opportunities to be recognized by us and
have relationships with us would all be
destroyed if they attack Taiwan or Hong
Kong or Singapore or Macau and as a
matter of fact it seems to serve their
advantage to have the separate windows
in and out for them and for others
dealing with them the Portuguese I think
there's reason to believe wanted to get
rid of Macau and which is analogous to
Hong Kong or Singapore and give it back
to the Chinese and the Chinese said oh
no you just stay here and keep on
running Macau that could become due to
the future of this issue what prospects
are there that the People's Republic and
Taiwan will negotiate their differences
in the Republic in the of China and the
People's Republic of China become one
what do you think tend to go water well
I have said to my friends in Taiwan that
if Red China were smart they would say
to the people of Taiwan the Chinese
people come home we guarantee you no
harm we won't lay a hand on you we want
you to develop our economy if they ever
did that in 20 years they'd be the
world's economic power I don't see Red
China with any great economic future as
sitting from here and looking ahead five
or ten years they have no money I'm
convinced that the big corporations that
have already gone in there American
corporations have gone in there with the
idea that if they lose the federal
government's going to make it up to them
I would hope that someday they could
develop into a great economy but I
served in China and you don't change in
agricultural people into an industrial
people overnight said it dull I would
think that there be an effort by the the
people of Taiwan as is referred to in
the amendment and the People's Republic
of China to negotiate some peaceful
solution I would hope it's peaceful
otherwise we ask some problems with the
bill passed by the Congress I hope there
will be I believe there will
the People's Republic has offered to
negotiate and the people in Taiwan and
they're the people that rule there have
been unwilling to do so up to noon but
what's really remarkable I think one of
the most remarkable things about the
visit advice premium dung here are the
conditions that Peking outlined that
would be acceptable to them for a coming
together of these two areas they said
that they could run their own show they
could keep their own system of Commerce
and Industry in other words private
enterprise they would be completely on
their own and most remarkable of all
dung said very clearly in response to a
specific question they will have no
objection to their maintaining their own
Armed Forces
now what this reminds one of is a
situation in the Middle Ages when dukes
like the Duke of Burgundy in France had
a whole area that he ran had his own
army he ran it to suit himself once a
year he'd go and bow to the King of
France and said you're the boss but then
he'd go back and run his his area the
way he wanted to and that really is the
kind of situation that Peking seems to
be contemplating as far as making a
coexistence with Taiwan and it's a
pretty attractive deal I would think to
the Taiwanese well I think you have to
remember one thing that the people who
are talking about our Chinese there's
no--there's their native Taiwanese but
they're in a great minority on Taiwan
and I would think it would be more in
the course of nature to expect brothers
and sisters and families to want to get
together again this would be the best
answer but whether or not the people the
Chinese living on Taiwan want to give up
a very brilliant economy to do that is
something we have to watch I don't fear
the invasion of Taiwan by the mainland
Chinese for maybe 20 years as you've
ever seen the fortifications on komoi if
I were the commanding general when they
said general
we want you to take from why I would it
take I would take a rest leave someplace
well it's they're very patient people
they've got a they can wait a hundred
years I guess but let us come to it to
the hundred years and Senator Goldwater
has touched on it the economic future of
China is of course critical to the
mutual good which can be shared by the
United States and China in this new
relationship can China using her most
plentiful resource people build a secure
economic future on agriculture cottage
and light high technology industry and
for instance utilize her labor-intensive
workforce to produce clothing for export
to most of the world does anybody did
you have anything we knew within China
recently that I don't think anybody can
really know but they do have the
intelligence of the people on Taiwan
they're the same people who have done so
miraculously we have seen how well other
agents have done in Korea and in Japan
economically now the People's Republic
seems to recognize the some of the
Maoist rigid doctrine and doctrinaire
approaches to economics and government
and society don't work they want Western
technology they're going to adopt some
of our practices I think in the course
of time we will see an emerging economy
that will be strong I think that's true
but we're going to see it you know push
comes to shove around the Congress on
trade and they start shipping textiles
in I assume the cotton producers in
California and another cotton producing
states will be looking to the Congress
for some non-tariff barrier protection
but it gets back to whether or not we're
going to give the People's Republic
China sort of not most favored nation
the sense that it Senator Cranston
indicated but give them let them bring
their goods to our country at less duty
and I don't think we should even
consider that until the People's
Republic of China become signatories to
the limited test ban treaty of 1963 and
the non-proliferation treaty I think
that has to be a condition before we
even consider FMF
status for the People's Republic of
China they had an explosion I think in
76 and we had to warn the people in
Connecticut that they might have
contaminated milk now if they're gonna
become one of the major powers in this
world and and abide by the laws that the
rest of us abide by and I think they
must show their good faith no I asked
primary by Supreme ear done when he was
here that very question and he indicated
that might not be necessary to have any
future nuclear detonations but they've
got some problems I mean they don't have
money they have a waxy content oil high
paraffin it's been suggested we trade
them Kansas wheat for that we have a lot
of wheat and they may enter into an
agreement for more grain products not
just from Kansas but from the Midwest as
you know we both you and I both raised
that question of the nuclear explosions
with Vice Premier dong and so did the
president I understand and we hope that
they will stop that because it does it
has a terrible effect in this country
but I wouldn't be able to agree with you
that we should that we can impose
conditions on on them because of their
failure to enter into the
non-proliferation treaty or the test ban
treaty after all France hasn't done that
and we have all kinds of relations with
France
od most favored nation including most
favored nation and many other trade
relationships so you know I don't
distrust the People's Republic of China
I guess I maybe should but I have a
little more trust in the French but if
my only point was I don't see how we can
impose a condition on them for most
favored nation that we haven't imposed
on other countries at this point is
there in your knowledge from your
conversations with vice premier Deng and
we all visit to China is China receptive
today in any sense to a mix of socialism
and free enterprise the technicians and
the managers now appear to have the
upper hand and may they not seek trance
plant the extraordinary economic success
of Taiwan to the mainland well if they
ever do we'd better watch out he said
time and again that they're all Chinese
and there's no difference between him
just because there's a hundred miles of
water sitting out there if they would go
the free market route I think they would
get to economic stability far faster
than trying to get there under socialism
with my humble opinion socialism has
been a complete failure wherever it's
been tried in the world I think there
are signs they might do what you suggest
the fact that they're willing to let
Taiwan continue its own economic system
if they got together the fact that they
want American industry and business to
come and they want American technology
indicates that they're going through a
rethinking as they plainly are of their
economy and their approach to economics
but plainly things are not totally
settled down there in any one pad and
they went through the Cultural
Revolution they went through the time
when Mao was a hero they're going
through a time when Mao is not quite
that heroic to them we can't tell
eventually who may come out on top and
what doctrines they will seek to impose
on China well let's turn to the question
of the stability of China politically is
there any possibility in your mind if
with your conversations with with
chairman Deng what we know what you know
of your visit is there any possibility
that China will see new political
turmoil like the Great Leap Forward and
the Cultural Revolution I for one
wouldn't want to make any predictions
about what's gonna happen in China in
the next six months or a year or ten
years these the changes they're in the
last year have been so startling and so
unexpected the fact that Mao from having
been that is virtually a guy the little
red book the answer to all questions is
now being seriously questioned it's just
extraordinary and there is there is
turmoil underneath I would suspect we
have some people have gone there and
reported that everything was just lovely
and the children was singing and
but he was happy I don't believe that it
goes very deep at all I think that much
as I despised the Soviet system and
deplore its repressive nature they do
have dissidents they do have groups that
express disagreement and and they get in
trouble for it but at least they're
there in China we don't know of any
dissidents at least we haven't until
very recently when a few people have
been able to put up wall posters that
criticize the government so I just
wouldn't want to make any predictions
about political stability in China the
president rather Brzezinski asked Deng
Xiaoping when he was here if there he
said the president encountered
opposition to normalization in this
country have you encountered opposition
in your country to dung shopping and he
said yes and paused and people at the
table lean forward wondering how
opposition manifested itself in the
dictatorship and he went on then to say
we encountered opposition in the
province of Taiwan I think I think
Jonathan you've got a wise approach but
I keep getting back to the fact that the
in the the mainland of China has not
changed a lot in the 30 years that the
Communists have conducted their
government once you get past the coastal
cities you you you lose that sort of a
government to facade of peace and
happiness they are still pretty much
controlled on the inland by the five
Geographic armies and you ask the
question will they support the central
communist government and the question
remains a question they don't know they
suppose they would but that's the his
the history of China has been those
Geographic armies that under warlords
and they're still under warlords that
have made China a pretty hard place to
understand but I would go along with you
I'd like to be around 20 or 25 years
from now and
see what the hell is going on over there
in spite of what your Democrats think
I'm going to be around when it's covered
the mutual benefits thoroughly that that
are available how large does China as a
potential market for America loomed for
the future well I don't know anybody who
knows I think there were a lot of a lot
of estimates made early on even last
December in January many people will be
of course visiting the People's Republic
of China many business leaders farmers
everybody looking for piece of the
action because there are billion people
there but I think dung shopping himself
has at least tried to balance that by
indicating that and they've recently
can't cancel the contracts with Japan
which is an indication that they're
certainly willing and in the bill passed
in the Congress in 78 called the export
stimulation act we provided for the
first time the authorization for credits
the People's Republic of China for
certain agriculture commodity so and
they're also in the in the process of
maybe some long term agreements as far
as the sale again of agricultural
products so everything there are a lot
of things working but I would be the
first to say that is probably not going
to be quite as grandiose as some they
may have anticipated they have the
people there may be a demand but I'm not
certain they have the resources now if
we can work out some exchange something
they have that might help to my
astonishment I find myself in full
agreement with Bob Dole let me get back
to what bob was saying many people who
live in the eastern part of the United
States have no idea of the tremendous
depth that we Westerners owe the Chinese
in fact I doubt that California or
Arizona would be as far along without
the help we received from those people
and I get back to the fact that we're
talking about Chinese
and they're all basically decent lovable
people the only group that we've had
arguments with have been those who took
over the government and made a communist
government out of it
but I think from the standpoint of
culture mutual education that we can
gain a lot probably before we ever gain
much in the way of trade I would guess
that it would be a long time before we
would export more to the mainland than
we do to Taiwan yes oh yes all right I
think we have spread a very large canvas
and it's time for the question and
answer session may I have the first
question please yes ma'am I missed your
key with the Asian affairs unit and I'm
the national coordinator and I'd like to
address this to Senator Dole senator
goldwater stated that the Chinese are
lovely people and I like to say we're
lovely and we're intelligent people but
I think that as Americans don't you
think we should develop a sensitivity to
Chinese as human beings and with people
and whether we're from Chinese from the
Taiwan or Republic of China or People's
Republic of China I like to know why you
made the statement that we shouldn't
trust the Chinese well I'm talking about
the Chinese leadership and I'm reminded
that in in the early 50s they gave Tibet
written assurances but the same kind
they they have given Taiwan that they
wouldn't be disturbed and I think you
all know what happened to Tibet and I
just suggest that we as I said in my
opening statement that we have to be
firm in our resolve I want to develop as
I've indicated a good relationship with
the people and I hope we can do that at
the same time we have to recognize that
it's a different government it's a
closed society it's totalitarian and we
have our own interest and I'm not so
certain you know if we go back and look
at the precedents whether the assurance
is given Taiwan really mean anything I
hope they do but I think you'll find an
even-handed policy depending on what
we hear from the People's Republic of
China I don't think that Bob Dole meant
that he didn't trust the people of China
I think he meant he didn't trust the
communist dictatorship government in the
People's Republic of China and I do not
either I don't trust any dictatorship
because we're one man or a handful of
men can make decisions for whatever
reasons it may not be in the best
interest of the people that they govern
and it certainly may not be in the best
interest of the people of our country I
think this is true of practically any
country in the world we say we don't
like the Russians we don't we wouldn't
trust the Russians I'd trust an
individual Russian I wouldn't trust
anybody in the port borough and I
wouldn't trust anybody in Peking in the
government but I trust the people that
live out in Kunming and chungqing and
other places in China what we say we
don't like people I know Bob is not
referring to the broad great spectrum of
Chinese people if you've ever known them
and lived with them as I have you love
my hell of a long time before you get
mad at me all right next question please
yes sir Jeff Gaynor director of foreign
policy story at the Heritage Foundation
my questions for congressman Bingham in
his statement earlier he alluded to the
statements that Dunc Xiao ping is made
about allowing Taiwan to continue to
have their own economic system possibly
your own military forces I just wonder
if he's aware of any time that this has
ever been said by dong in which he did
not have offered the precondition that
they must abandon essentially their
their claim as a government take down
their flag break diplomatic relations
with all their governments and effects
say that Pei King is the sovereign over
Taiwan and if these are the conditions
for it just how meaningful is this
especially since later on you yourself
said you did not believe you in the
future what would happen in the PRC in
regards to leadership changes how Taiwan
could rely upon something like this
simply because of certain statements
dong is made well as I think I said in
my statement earlier Dunn made that
statement in relation to the question if
Taiwan and Peking get together and can
resolve their differences under what
conditions would you contemplate this
occurring and and he made those answers
in relation to that so he was not
talking about the current situation but
about a hope for rapprochement between
the province of Taiwan as they consider
it in the mainland so far as the the
intermediate or the interim situation is
concerned I would agree with what
senator Cranston said earlier that the
the real security for Taiwan lies in the
fact first of all that the United States
will continue to supply arms the big
change in the Chinese position last fall
that really permitted this all is to
take place was that they indicated they
would not protest the continued
furnishing of arms to Taiwan by the
United States and that was really what
made possible all this development I
think but the the real security lies not
in in any assurances that they give but
in the fact that they would lose
everything that they want if they attack
Taiwan I think the certainly our
information our intelligence is that
they don't have the capacity to attack
Taiwan but more than that they would
lose the good relations with us the
commercial relations the technology all
of that that they are obviously so
anxious to obtain so I think therein
lies the security of Taiwan not in any
promises if they make dung it's also
stated that that the people in Taiwan
are perfectly free to maintain their own
army even after whatever normalization
may occur between Taiwan and the
People's Republic and it's in that army
that would be under their control in
Taiwan that they have their main
assurances that things don't work well
they still have a way to defend
themselves but I think there it goes
back to the basic and again we don't
want to rehash that ground but there was
no effort to preserve the mutual defense
treaty by the administration and
we do have a one-year moratorium on arms
sales and so I I don't quarrel with what
we all hope will happen but I do think
we're gonna have a a long time
obligation at Taiwan I think we have one
one thing that's come about as a result
of the obligation and in spite of what
we've done in the Congress with the
passage of the Act we've talked about
we're still faced with the impossibility
of our government doing business with a
non-government it's like doing business
with a Chamber of Commerce under this
present situation and I can see it
advantageous to both countries in the
areas of culture of academics but when
it gets down to the final question can
there be two Chinese armies two Chinese
air forces I don't think Taiwan will
have a say about it I think it will be
Peking whether we like it or not it
might be of interest to in relation to
that question just to refer to the
wording of the conference report on the
legislation affecting Chinese relations
Taiwanese relations and that is a
statement that it's the policy of the
United States to make clear that to a
bang upon to consider any effort to
determine the future of Taiwan by other
than peaceful means including by
boycotts or embargoes a threat to the
peace and security of the western
Pacific and of grave grave concern to
the United States that language is
really not too different from the
language that was in the mutual defense
treaty and we retain all the rights to
go to the defense of Taiwan or take
whatever other military steps are deemed
in our interest without the mutual
defense treaty that we had under the
mutual defense treaty and there was no
guarantee under the mutual defense
treaty that we would go to the aid of
Taiwan if Taiwan was in difficulty what
it said was that we would consider what
action was appropriate in accordance
with their constitutional procedure I
think even under the language of that a
congressman has
we have made no commitment to Taiwan
we've merely said it will we will look
on it gravely so that's about what does
in the mutual defense treaty is as Alan
just pointed out we give the money
unconditional commitment and the defense
there's a little more muscle with a
mutual defense treaty than there is an
agreement with the Chamber of Commerce
but I but I think beyond that Congress
must have must get high marks for the
changes made in the legislation
Democrats and Republicans I think it was
nonpartisan bipartisan effort to
strengthen the legislation and they did
a good job next question please
professor of political science miracle
from Moscow it was very interesting to
me to hear what's another doll and
representative being told about their
discussion with vice-premier Deng
Xiaoping about China joining nuclear
non-proliferation treaty and so on and
it was very positive moment but from the
other side we have a lot of statement
that United States desire to play
Chinese card against the Soviet Union it
is general oppression with United States
don't try to prevent Chinese invasion of
Vietnam and so on and I'm very I see
some contradiction here of course
now after normalization of relations
with China and after afterward with
China so it's such big interest engaging
American technology American economic
help and so on United States get some no
not substantial but some levers to
influence Chinese policy I could you
give us your question please oh yes I
and I'm interested to know
what is the opinion in what direction
substantially United States will now try
to influence you know Chinese policy in
direction for example to press China to
join non-proliferation treaty partial
nuclear test ban treaty denouncing of
theories of inevitability of war between
China between the United States and so
on or in all right
would you like start sending dog I think
we discussed it earlier I just hope that
maybe we went a bit too far and saying
we'd require that before we would grant
him a most favored nation or whatever
the better trade status but I would hope
that we might ask some assurances from
the leaders of the People's Republic of
China it seems to me when Vice Premier
said to all of us on the Senate side
after in responding to the question
raised that he didn't see any need for
further detonations but I'm not certain
that's enough assurance I think we can
we can suggest and the president's
discussed that with the Vice Premier
hopefully they'll be responsive yes and
just in general I don't think we have
very much leverage or will have much
leverage over the People's Republic of
China in regard to their foreign policy
even though they want our trade and our
credit and our technology I don't think
they're going to accept any conditions
or what we tell them to do in the
foreign policy field or in the domestic
policy field anymore than the Soviet
Union does the Soviet Union also wants
trade with us what's credits from us
once our technology but we haven't been
remarkably successful in influencing the
Soviet Union's foreign policy for
example in Africa next question please
my name is Philip rice and I'm from
Stanford University and I was wondering
how our human rights program would be
directed towards China especially since
they support you know Cambodia which the
Pol Pot regime regime which was
extremely bloody are we gonna does a
pinning up a posters fit our you know
compliance with a human rights program
or are we gonna press it like we do with
the Soviet Union or I was to me was one
of the weakening points of the
president's decision a man that we can't
we can't disagree with President
Carter's insistence on Human Rights we
all agree with it but why he should
recognize a government that has probably
been the cause of more deaths by murder
than any government in the history of
man including Genghis Khan I don't know
and I've asked that question time and
again why should we recognize a country
with such a bad record in human rights
but it seems that we go out of our way
to beat down the countries that have
tried to do a little bit in human rights
ii and raised to the pinnacle those
countries that have made an absurdity
out of it that's my opinion
certain question recognition really
should be a step that we take when we
are convinced that a given government
governs our given people in a given
geographical area and it should not be
based upon our liking or not liking the
way that particular government behaves
on human rights or other matters if we
were only going to recognize our friends
and deal with their friends we wouldn't
have diplomatic relations with very many
nations and it seems to me the talking
to people with whom we have deep
differences and who are potential
adversaries is a way to avoid or reduce
the danger of conflict if you have no
relationship with them where you can
talk things out you're more apt to fall
into misunderstandings that can lead to
conflict alright this concludes another
public policy forum presented by the
American Enterprise Institute for Public
Policy Research
on behalf of a EEI our heartfelt thanks
to the distinguished members and expert
panelists Senator Robert dole senator
Barry Goldwater senator Alan Cranston
and representative Jonathan B Bingham
and to our guests and our experts in the
audience for their participation this
public policy forum on the future of
us-chinese relations has been presented
by AEI the American Enterprise Institute
it brought you the views of four experts
in the field it is the aim of AEI to
illuminate important issues of the day
by presenting many viewpoints in the
hope that by so doing those who wish to
learn about the decision-making process
will benefit from such a free exchange
of informed and enlightened opinion I'm
John Degnan in Washington this public
policy forum series is created and
supplied to this station as a public
service by the American Enterprise
Institute Washington DC
[Music]
for a transcript of this program send
$3.75 to the American Enterprise
Institute 11:50 17th Street Northwest
Washington DC 2 0 0 3 6
[Music]